these glasses are fake you got pranked
so hard I'm so embarrassed for you oh my
god
subscribe is this focus you know is this
too bright yeah yeah that's slightly
more miserable hi guys my name is grace
Helbig if you do not know now you know
your life is different now I'm drinking
coffee out of a mug with a picture of my
dog on it I'm recording this video
before I have to go pick her up from
boarding my life is fun I decided to do
another shoe of consciousness video this
week because they're fun for me to do I
like them very much and maybe you do too
or maybe you hate them so Endor oh oh hi
this is my microphone that's
embarrassing huh I got pranked so hard
it's Friday you made it through the week
congratulations is there anything you
want to tell me stop telling me stop it
stop it what's been happening this week
I don't know because all the days have
blend together into one just long day
where sometimes it's bright outside and
sometimes it's not bright outside
one thing that happened is I got a
little drunk at the end of a long night
and it was post debates so it was
warranted we all handle our anger
differently and it just really hit me
that snapchat filters are weird so many
girls are using these animal filters and
putting them on their face like they're
sexy but that's just like a vague form
of bestiality sexify animals trying to
incite romantic feelings of sexual
animals I got really grossed out by it
and I went on snapchat to talk about it
this is a dog and every girl thinks that
they look sexy with this dog this animal
it's a deer this animal junggigo my
dad's car when I was in eighth grade
and it got remover and it died does that
make it sexy social media soap box
perfect choice Who am I to judge maybe
just all these pretty girls putting the
dog food
on them maybe it's not trying to look
sexy and maybe Donald Trump is trying to
make America great again let me go to
Twitter moments that's where I find all
of my information about everything these
days Joe Biden got to take his 67
Corvette out for the third time as VP
well that's a fishing interesting news
story if you guys decided on your
Halloween costumes cool for you
good job what's what's what are you on
Monday there's a dead moth laying on the
top of my desk and it's hauntingly
beautiful don't you say that was
hauntingly beautiful I didn't know grace
had any emotions through him there's
been a moth flying around this room for
the last three days and now it's just
face up dead on my desk what subtle
mafia has place this beautiful moth face
up dead on my desk you got to see this
look at dad this is what a lock looks
like up close what though that's
beautiful you want to touch them because
what if it does like rigor mortis and
then me pops up that's all collectively
think about mortality for all but hell
okay have whoo now let's all
collectively just push the panic attacks
back down ah we're back I fake glasses
that's sad right that's sad
the sad thing this isn't cute right this
isn't cute this one sad that glass is
sad but girls is dogs sexy got it thank
you society house cool push that subject
I'm gonna go see pentatonix tonight I'm
very excited you've probably by now seen
the snapchat story of me seeing
pentatonics and I guarantee I lost my
goddamn mind
I like concerts I get too excited about
being excited the meegan excited about
being excited in combination with me
being super excited to see people with
genuine talent that are like achieving
their potential I'm gonna be screaming
in them snaps tonight all the snapchat
talk to you guys follow me on snapchat
my name is dump [ __ ] is real you're like
I hate it it feels so narcissistic it's
so self-serving
but someone took grace helbig who took
grace helbig give it to me is how you
calmly negotiate with someone oh is it a
national holiday today
let's look up everyday holidays let's
see what today's holiday is bizarre
wacky holidays three different were you
trying to hold up a number three
different holidays according to this
website
babbling day congratulations a babies
you got your day and Brooks Lakes count
your buttons day not count your
blessings count your buttons but Tom's
count your but ons
I have one button and it is button in my
pants on my pants and it's National
pumpkin cheesecake day also oh but we
missed this today I'm recording this on
the 20th Thursday
it was branded fruit day who gets into
side days who gets to decide today
excuse me day deciders Association may I
please decide a day sincerely grace and
hoping the first Oh saturday is nut day
this is my career this is my career and
Tuesday the 25th get ready sourest day
whoa national baloney day is the 24th we
got mark that down we should do
something to celebrate some reason I
feel very excited for that holiday also
the 29th is Hermit day
that's my holiday I can't wait to
celebrate that from the comfort of my
own home if you had to create a holiday
what holiday would you create excuse me
remember that moth that was dead it's
still dead it's right there it's just I
don't want to touch it this is where I
realize that I have trust issues is
because I don't believe that it's fully
dead and I don't want to touch it
because if it comes alive I will get
scared and it's definitely dead but I am
not 100% convinced this moth has been
flying around this room for three days
and I have a feeling it's a great
actor tress I don't you gender-fluid
okay you mock so gender more importantly
do moths have an agenda well this has
been a really great time guys thanks for
dealing with my shoe of consciousness
video
I like making these a lot they're fun I
should probably just do live streams
that seems like the better stream for a
consciousness but if you like these let
me know give this video a thumbs up if
you want me to make more of these cuz
these are fun and I kind of like doing
these every Friday as like a roundup of
the week cuz I haven't blogged for a
while maybe I'll start going again soon
but it maybe not who knows inconsistency
at its best I'm wearing my trump support
shirt I hope you guys have a great
weekend and I hope that you do something
that is interesting and fun to you and
that makes you happy that was genuine
and sincere I know that that didn't
sound genuine insincere but that was me
actually being genuine and sincere which
is a little sad but not as sad as so i'm
all i've there's a spectrum i don't know
[Music]
I'm sorry I forgot that tell me